my problem i don't know you personally
but i i have a problem with women that
openly accuse a man of doing something
and you didn't press charges
like and so so because i don't know you
i don't know him how do we know who's
telling the truth and that's why that's
why the law comes in and so then we we
have where people on this podcast they
know your ex-boyfriend like if you dated
him for five years where you're ruining
a man's reputation and nobody knows
what's true because the law didn't come
in okay so then i'll tell you something
about the law when you work your ass off
as a man and you have the law on your
side because you're a woman okay
sometimes the law does fail the law
there's no it doesn't kill women women
are literally power when it comes to law
wait the law in relationships is totally
different the law and the emotions is
totally different do you understand and
that's what i think is also important to
know because the same way a man works
his ass off and then he gets married and
there's a divorce there's no prenup and
the woman takes half of his money he's
upset but the law is there for a reason
do you understand that section i don't
know
that the allah that the law isn't fair
on everybody and the law and the law
women have more than advice and that's
what i'm trying to say and the law is
completely unfair to men especially
black men so me as a black woman that
understands the black struggle i will
never ever put a man in that situation
unless he's done something
right what i did
let me flesh it out so what you're
saying is because somebody's black and
they're punching you in the face you're
not gonna call the police on them
because they're black i'll explain
something to you again because i will
tell you this i don't give a damn what
color you are you punch me in the face
the cops are coming okay and this is
what i'm trying to explain to you and
this is how i'm trying to because the
bottom line is you attacked me yeah yeah
that's fantastic and i get all of that
and this is why we then want to pull
things black and white but there's
always a great area when you which is
the name of the show
and i'm trying to get there because this
is the thing
i you you may have hurt me you may have
done terrible things to me but i love
you you are my man i don't want harm to
come to you because i'm a nurturer i
actually fall in love with you i've
taken care of you i've cooked for you
i've invested my emotions into you which
means you've punched me and i'm going to
sentence you to a whole year in prison
unfortunately i'm in the situation that
i mean i don't actually want to see that
to happen okay so they punch you again
if that and that's how people get into
it and then why did they punch you again
listen and that's how people get into
really serious relations right so so a
man's punched you three four five six
seven eight times right and not once
have you called the police and not once
you think you know what this prob this
person probably deserves jail so what
you're going to do instead what you're
going to do instead is that you're going
to have the person who consistently and
continuously punches you in your face
living in your own home okay that's what
you're going to do and this is why i'm
going to now bring it back to the old
traditions and why actually people
stayed in relationships probably for
longest they'd marry until the end of
their lives because actually men was
quite abusive back in the day mentally
they would be like no it's true men be a
man beating a woman back in the day was
not a problem what day i wanted to six
years let me tell you let me tell you i
know this because i know my granddad
used to be my my your grandmother your
granddad is not enough information
listen in african culture especially
this is the norm and i don't have to go
for statistics because i'm a black woman
and i i know i live i know victimhood
mentality listen no no wait let me
finish and tell you so back in the day
even though it was a
does there's an american show that even
they take the piss out of him in america
in family guy where they say pow right
in the kisser which is a man in the tv
on tv back in the 20s or 30s or whatever
and the joke was that he used to punch
his wife whenever she took rubbish right
because domestic violence against a
woman back in there was actually a
little bit more acceptable and less
founded upon against by the way i agree
wait because
because actually a woman is meant to be
mass property so the way in which women
paint men no no no this is it's amazing
to me as a man i'm just asking the way
you're painting your weight because what
you're basically saying because there's
no statistical data for what you're
saying first of all there's no
i mean
if if we were to go back to i don't know
what what year type like frame are you
talking about right now right what time
frame are you talking about generally
like from even my mom's generation so
what special culturally successful
70s 70s over the 90s so if you have
statistical data from the 70s to show
what
domestic violence was like back then
then i would hear you out but the way
you're painting men is is because when
you're talking you're talking as if the
majority of men in the 1970s were just
coming home and beating their wives no
no right because because that's that's
what it sounds like
can i give you guys a data point that
people don't really talk about um so the
majority of domestic abuse situations
they're punching each other so a lot of
times girls will say like oh i was in an
abusive relationship but if you're
hitting back you're both hitting each
other like that that's that's mutual
abuse yeah yeah yeah it's okay i'm not
i'm looking okay okay let me
go let's go
so and the thing is we have this
perception that men beat women more than
women beat men but it's not true women
beat men when it's one-sided abuse women
beat men seventy percent of the time
cool where it's it's only thirty percent
so i i think so so this like narrative
this narrative where it's like women are
being abused and always have been abused
throughout all of history it's not true
women women women were protected
throughout all of history like men had
to go to wars they always were
protecting women they're i'm sure they
were one-off situations
so you said you were in an abusive
relationship right you said you're in an
abusive relationship at any point in
time did the two of you have
a physical education of course because
when somebody's been causing me so which
means you're also what you're talking
about but no but what i'm trying to
explain let me tell you something yeah i
said so you were also an abuser let me
ask well i would be because i'm
defending myself in self-defense if i
was to take all of this evidence to
court actually i would remember okay so
not to do that though but no because
after a while somebody's hitting me i
still love him but you're doing things
to me i'm going to defend myself okay
but you're hitting him
of course because so if a girl is
hitting me let's say a girl punches me
bro and a guy punches the girl back at
self-defense that's not going to be
looking at self-defense in the court let
me tell you something yeah i'll explain
going back going back
going back to our saying first of all
i'm trying to to bring to the table that
women being lonely and they're being
issues with be within relationships
between men and women is not just
because women are more than women now
are this there's so many other factors
that we're not even factoring in and
we're generalizing women like for
example the fact that back in the day
people would stay marriages for longer
and they were marrying if they were
getting married more because back in the
day certain things were more acceptable
no no no no back in the day
women see this society back in the day
women had to chase men women were
basically the properties of men things
were traditional hence why relationships
would no longer okay and this is what
i'm saying and there are consequences
and things were traditional and that is
why a lot of women stayed in unhappy
marriages that's why a lot of women were
abused as well and that's why the
statistics will not show that these
women yeah they were married forever but
they were completely unhappy and they
were abused which i'm trying what i'm
trying to say is that not every single
person that is married is in a good
marriage the the men and women being
together is not just because um they
need to stay together and everything is
happy no women are lonely now also down
to their trauma also down to the fact
that modern men are not also great down
to the fact that modern women as well
are also not great but within all of
that there's too many different
subcategories that we are not thinking
about and we judge and we point fingers
i will point fingers at women because i
know we're slacking in somewhere in
different ways the fact that sometimes
when you feel entitled because oh i went
to uni and i'm somebody no i understand
you went to uni it's great
congratulations but that doesn't make
you have more or less than anything you
just weren't talking about you got three
degrees and i'll tell you right and you
know why i say that because the reason
why i'm happy that i got is because like
i said i proved to myself that if i work
hard i can get results so my mental
power has increased
we don't give a [ __ ] but you should give
a [ __ ] no why should i do you know what
you should do
no do you know why you should give a
[ __ ] because when your children are in
school and they need support from the
parent and you're out there working it's
going to be me that's going to help oh
you can't be the teacher that's going to
be teaching me it's going to be me
that's going to give them the grace i'll
tell you it's going to be those three
cards
when a kid when a kid comes to me says
mommy i need help with the homework that
is at work who's going to help mommy so
i should clap for you that if my kid
comes and tells you what's supposed to
be
i just have a question why do you keep
trying to tell them what they should
want no i'm not saying well no no like
i'm basically i'm just doing it i'm just
being honest i'm using the words that
are coming out of your mouth like i'm
just i'm just repeating what you're
saying back to you i'm i'm listening
and and you're you're telling them what
they should want because they said we
don't care and then you defend it so so
you're telling men what they should be
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait just just hang on just take
what she just said in i thought sorry
i'll go back and i'll explain the reason
why i'm not telling because there's a
different there's a difference between
wants and needs what men want a lot of
the time sometimes it doesn't even make
sense because what your life is going to
turn out to be doesn't work with what er
what it is that you want whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa so that's for example
how do you know the reason why how do
you i just have a question how do you
know i'll tell you this because he's
telling me but what so
is your kids gonna gonna are you gonna
be the teacher to your kid yeah i'm
gonna be a teacher to my kids i don't
mean [ __ ] oh it does mean [ __ ] you know
what it means it means that actually
under pressure and under really really
in the situation where i have to
multitask a lot and stay focused with
the task at hand and maintain my life
maintain my social life and take care of
somebody i can do it because i did it
whilst i was in relationships and in
difficult situations so my journey to
get to the end result is what i carry
let me let me switch
something as well because
that's good
then
ladies let me ask you a question right
as many of you know i was just banned on
tick-tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible